Welcome to-
FRI
AAAHH
It's time for me to review your submissions
I asked you to photoshop these pictures, and now I'm going to review them..
And for next week we got a new topic!
If you're a musician, it's time to- to get your..
Music..aly on?
I'm going to add a bunch of, eh, audios
You can sample, it whatever way you want, just make-
make up a song, make a jamming song.
If you got that beat,
Let it f-f-f-f-f-flow
...
Okay!
*claps*
Let's go, let's..
Let's review this shit!
...
*Pewds already questions life*
Well, it said it was for free.
So I mean, I'll take it ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
*laughs*
Good photoshop.
Extremely attractive.
I don't know what else to say, really..
*laughs*
Okay.
Sure.
Whatever.
Good job.
GOOD JOB.
GOOOOD JOB.
For Fuck's sake!
What's with the content jokes?
I have PLENTY of content. ( r u sure?)
You-
Fine, Jesus..
If, if- if I didn't have any content
Then explain why I'm hunting myself!
Okay, explain that!
Flawed logic!
You can't argue with facts!
...
F- you
"The pupil of your eye can expand over 45% when you see something that you love"..
*looks deeply*
Well, this is just science.
Again.
Stop, stop this.
Aww- :3
It's so cute with Edgar though..
Heh
WHAT THe actu-ahaha
*laughs*
That's kind of awesome.
I don't know why you didn't make the center point-
Buht watever.
It's cool.
I appreciate it.
Like I'd-
I'd buy it.
WOAH
What is that?
*burps like Rick boi*
That's pretty cool.
"PewDie Loop"?
*loading PewDieLoop*
WOOOOAAAAHHH-
AHAha!
That's creative.
That's pretty fucking cool.
Well done-
Well done, "Ompalompan"..
Great name by the way.
"I'm punk, so I must rebel"
"I'm asian, so I must like maths"
"I dye my hair crazy colors,
*laughs*
so I must be looking for-"
"I'm the biggest channel on YouTube, so I MUST make
*laughs*
billions and millions"..
Billions and millions is the shittiest meme
I've ever seen
and for some reason, you guys keep posting that-
*laughs*
"Pewdiepie good suck"
"Blonde Swedish man gets succed-"
O- okay
Alright
Great
Appreciate, uh, Pornhub h-hitting me up though
with the- with a VIP account ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
...
I mean.
Nothing.
Nothing happened
Cocaine.
Marijuana.
Resp-
*laughs*
Everyday broo!
Respecting wahmen, bro!
Now, That's just sexy.
I think I did a..
thumbnail like this once.
But that's, uh-
that's pretty good.
I would eat it.
I would, uh..
Rub it on my body ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*why*
WOW, we look so real.
*SARCASM 101*
I- I almost can't tell that this isn't-
I remember it though..
that one time me and Fake Marzia had a child together
"Do you think God stays in Heaven
because he is afraid of what he created?"
*laughs*
Hey, Don't photoshop Brad.
okay
He hasn't deserved it.
Fuck this-
this is the worst meme.
"Thank You
For
Making
Not you
Quality Conte-"
*laughs*
Thank you.
I have the nicest
viewers on YouTube.
You guys are
too kind.
What have I done
to deserve
such a wonderful audience
that truly appreciates me.
*SARcaSm 101*  (•-•)
What are you-
fucking gay?
*questions life*
*kill me* *wot m8*
Alright
Well this video is done.
Thank you guys.
So much.
Uh
I got a-
I got a, uh-
Dentist appointment.
*oh bai doggie*
*pewds?*
*guys he gone 4 evr*
That was a joke.
I'm still here.
*laughs*
Nothing like a good old respecting wahmen meme.
GOD DAMMIT.
It's not true
by the way
*sure* *yeah ok*
if it was myself there,
then we can talk.
"PewDiePie is not original, copi-"
WHAT
No
Jacksfilms copied me. *hehe*
Everyone knows that.
He's ripping off my whole formula.
My whole thing.
I did Y.I.A.Y. way before Jacksfilms, guys.
"[Felix] Aww,
ain't you the cutest little thing.
[Katy Perry] 'Is math related to science?'
[Felix] Oh no...
it's retarded."
Oh.
Katy Perry.
What happened?
"Where can I find myself a relationship like-"
Oh right, okay
Yeah, no
It's another Bret..
We do look very cute in that picture,
Not gonna lie.
We do look way cuter in that picture,
than any of these other ones.
*laughs*
WOAH *late earrape warning*
That's fucking awesome!
Hell yeah!
I-*burps like Rick*
I always wanted to eat Jack. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) ;)
*le rick burp*
Aw man, that's really cool!
ha
Fair enough
Well played.
See,
Even if you're shit,
You can still make it
There is hope for everyone.
"Did I spend too much time on this?
Yes.
Do I regret it?
Yes"
NO it's fucking awesome!
Hell yeah!
Well done.
I love it.
I look like a-
I like the Edgar in the background as well.
*laughs*
Alright, we're going to the final page.
So these best be good.
Okay.
Fuck, maybe I should do a fan art competition
because these are fucking awesome.
Very cool.
Very nice.
uh.
absolutely.
beautiful.
The anatomy of this, uh, whamen,
is uh, flawless.
Oh, God. What the fuck is this?
No, just no, okay, just no
*laughs*
"Sweden is my city."
"Are you religious?"
"Me: the book of respecting women"
What can I say?
The pugs awakens?
*hehe look at markimoo*
Haha, I just saw Edgar, so cute!
And Marzia looks amazingly disfigured. Well done.
Uh, really, you really hit the nail on that one..
"The Pugs Awakens"
Okay
Alright
GOD DAMMIT.
"he respect"
"but he also attac"
*laughs*
Well done. That was good. I like that one.
WOAHH *earrape again*
That's fucking awesome!
Jesus Christ, that's terrifying
Why am I so turned on right now?
Excuse me. I have to do something.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) *dats a naughty pewds*
Just kidding.
I'm still here.
That's fucking awesome. Well done, Goesses.
" I am pregananant"
You're retardadardadard.
*error*
"But this isn't photoshop."
Yes, it is, okay
Don't believe the lies of the media.
Or the reddit comments.
"cocaine"
"marijuana"
"beer"
"disrespectin-"
Of course it has to make it back again!
*laughs*
"Pewds get rekt at SGDQ"
"I would really prefer if you stop doing ' Try not to' challenges." (¬_¬)
*laughs*
aww~
awwww~
Well done.
Well- Well use of the
shitty source material that I gave you guys
Okay
NO
THAT IS WRONG
THAT IS FACTUALLY INCORRECT
"Pewds should be 720p,
he never uploads 1080p."
Yeah, that's right. I still have shitty internet.
"This person tried to-"
*laughs*
I, I- have nothing to fear
that's how you know your phone is safe
*laughs*
For fuck's sake.
Seriously?
*laughs*
That should have been the thumbnail of that video..
God dammit
ALRIGHT!
So the last one, the top one goes to MassiveWeebYT
*laughs*
"Nice touch in the background-"
Oh come on!
"What's her name?"
Of course!
Uh, excuse me.
My name is PewDiePie, alright.
I'm a little offended that you misgendered me
*laughs*
Okay!
That was it for this week's
uh
Friday's with Pewdiepie!
Honestly, I love these.
I think these are my favorite weekly videos to do.
I know everyone's like oh, oh
Oh, he's out of ideas
because he asked his fans
but
I think it's cool. I think it's fun.
And uh,
uhh
Yeah, I don't know it's not that great actually I think about it
It's the same shit over and over basically
But if you think you have the skills for next week to make it into video
*i doooo pewds*
Check out the link in the description
make the most LIT song possible
and
You will make it, to the next level
My name is Pewdiepie, and this has been Bro Awesome
That was so cringe. I don't know where I was going with that. SISTER FISTER!
*I've been subbing this for 2 hours..*
*ive subbed for 40 mins... added some dank memes here and there..*
*I need sleep*
*same @ 12:40*
*thanks for watching guys!*
*yip yip*
BOI =) HURRRAAAYYYY